[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain a science fiction film called
last sunrise
spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
at the beginning of the movie a voice
narrates to us about the current
condition of the world
he claims that air conditioning oxygen
and sunrise are some of the most
important things in the world but now
the world is void of all of these
the narrator cannot remember how many
days it has been since the sun collapsed
because it is difficult to tell with no
sunrise a few years ago people used all
the fossil fuels and everyone turned to
solar energy for their basic needs the
narrator laughs at people who used to
say no matter what happens the sun will
rise tomorrow because that is not true
anymore
the sun has completely shut down and the
world has no source of fuel anymore
cut to the day it all started the story
takes place in a futuristic china where
everything is almost fully powered by
solar energy
a young man named sun yang is woken up
by a futuristic ai robot named ilsa yang
analyzes the satellite data from a
multi-million dollar company called
helios
helios is the manufacturer of solar
power that fuels three-fourths of china
its ceo named wang is the center of this
historical change and is praised for his
accomplishments
yang analyzes helios satellite data and
updates it on his website as he does
this task yang is bothered to see a
nearby star disappear he claims that the
disappearance of this star has some
effect on the sun itself
however the ai robot reminds him that
such a deduction doesn't follow the law
of conservation of energy so it is not
possible
when yang gets out of his apartment we
see every street in every shop using
solar panels manufactured by helios
in the background the company broadcasts
the development of solar energy in
district 4 the only district left for
helios to take over its logo is
everywhere
the following day yang is woken up by an
emergency alarm on his computer
he finds out that the sun's luminosity
has dropped by 15 and is continuing to
drop quickly the ai tells yang that his
assumption about the star was accurate
yang quickly tells ilsa to call helio
ceo wang
yang asks wang if he knew that the son
was going to die today wang instead
questions him what he would do if today
was the end of the world
when yang says he would find a way to
survive wang gives him an address and
asks him to come there if he survives
today yang then barges into his
neighbor's apartment to get a better
view of the sunrise as he stands on the
windows he sees the sun flicker
his neighbor chen mu is confused as to
why he is here and asks him to go away
but yang doesn't even blink his eyes as
he watches the sun die tvs start to
broadcast the event unfold and reports
of a flickering moon from the other side
of the world are hurt
suddenly the flickering starts getting
violent and everything goes dark within
seconds
yang goes back to his room as chen mu
follows him asking what is going on
he ignores her and asks elsa what is
going to happen now ilse informs him
that the temperature is going to drop to
zero fahrenheit in a week and minus 100
fahrenheit in a year oxygen will slowly
deplete all forms of life will disappear
and the earth will become a frozen
planet yang asks chen mu to leave the
city and goes out himself
people are confused and panicking the
grocery store is full of people trying
to stock up supplies but the cashier
cannot check out because of lack of
power the lights are still working but
they will be out in 24 hours
yang takes a bottle of water and a map
to help him find the location wang had
told him about on his way out he is
walking through a dark alley and a
mugger hits him unconscious and injures
his leg
he then takes his money
when he opens his eyes again elsa
announces to him that he has slept for
12 hours and 18 minutes
he rushes back to his apartment and
packs his clothes in some instant
noodles chen meu is at his door with her
backpack asking for his help to call her
parents yang tells her there is no way
he can help her and asks her to go away
however when she mentions owning a car
the two decide to travel together before
starting the journey chanmeu makes yang
promise that he will take her to her
parents house after they visit ceo wang
the two then leave for the place and
encounter a large traffic jam on the way
shenmue gets out of the car to go to the
washroom and yang takes this opportunity
to drive away but is stopped by a crowd
when she is back she asks him why he is
not in the place they parked and he lies
saying that he was making a u-turn the
two finally reach wang's home at night
and meet other people who happen to be
stranded there
they drink around the fire while a
socially anxious yang stays in a corner
later his watch runs out of battery and
elsa stops talking to him the death of
the ar robot saddens gang as she was his
only friend
chen meun notices this and tries to
comfort him the two talk and bond
later when they wake up yang asks wang
what his plan is
since wang is a billionaire yang
believes that he has a way to survive
to his distress wang claims that this
situation is beyond repair he wants to
stay in the place until death comes
according to wang a highly advanced
civilization from far in space is
harvesting energy from other stars and
simultaneously terminating life on other
planets
this time the earth is their target and
they have been successful a wormhole has
been created in the center of the solar
system and with a lack of gravity all
the planets will soon fly away from the
system including the earth
in the end wang gives yang the
coordinates of a location of district 4
and tells him he should go there if he
really wants to survive
when chen mu wakes up the two continue
their journey the temperature has fallen
exponentially so much that yang's bottle
of water freezes shenmue notices a space
shuttle taking off and yang comments
that it might be rich people trying to
fly away to another planet to stay alive
he drives chanmu to her parents home as
promised and continues his journey to
the place wang told him about
however he notices chen meu had left her
planned in her car and goes back to
return it when he gets there he finds a
distressed chen mew alone in the house
she doesn't speak a word unlike her
usual talkative self
all of the people of the town had left
in the time of emergency
we see the fish aquarium in the house is
freezing
yang goes inside a room and is horrified
to see both her parents dead in the bed
he takes a letter from her father's hand
and brings it back to chenmiu it turns
out that they were preparing for chen
mu's arrival before the death of the sun
as they wrote her the letter asking her
to take care of herself in the city a
group of thugs entered the house and
killed both of them
chenbyu breaks down crying when yang
tells her that he too is an orphan and
doesn't know who his parents are
he asks her to come with him to district
4 the place wang told him about the two
then continue their journey
after a while they reached district 3
and are surprised how the map brought
them the wrong way their cars battery is
dying so they go a little forward and
see a house selling electricity
when they go in an old couple welcomes
them and claims they have electricity
that they extract from coal
however the woman then locks chan mew
inside the washroom and snatches the car
keys from yang they apologize as they
take the car and drive away
shenmue and yang are in distress they
are close to district 4 but yang's leg
injury from the time the thug hit him is
getting worse
he tells jen mu to go there alone but
she insists she won't leave without yang
after much thinking they make their way
to district 4 on foot on their way they
rest for a while feeding on instant
noodles and watching the beautiful and
cruel night sky without the sunlight it
looks astonishingly beautiful
when they reach the city area again they
find their car deserted by the side of
the road
but just then a group of mine workers
comes looking for them
to save chen mu yang turns himself in
they take him to their headquarters and
keep him as one of the mine workers to
extract coal chen mu however doesn't
give up and goes to rescue yang with
just a pepper spray
she manages to free him from the place
but yang gets shot in the process
when they are back in the car chen mu
drives to district 4 at full speed
hoping to save yang they stop at
district 4's entrance and yang realizes
that the place has geothermal energy
that can save them they continue their
journey and see the car's windows and
the roads starting to freeze they do not
have a lot of time but just then their
car runs out of battery and stops
with no way out the two stay together on
the back seat holding each other's hand
an automated voice from the car says
that the two are experiencing their last
moments on the earth after a while
chanmu calls yang's name but he doesn't
answer
crying she places her head on his
shoulder and falls asleep while freezing
sometime later a car stops beside theirs
a couple comes out of it and brings
unconscious yang and chen mu with them
they drive the two to a safe place in
district four
in the end a voice in the background
narrates that the earth is moving at
high speed into another galaxy
soon they will reach their new home
which has three suns
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching